bidets are back the church of what's
happening now would love to introduce
you to hello tushy
go to hellotushy.com and they have
portable devices that spray your butt
clean with water go to hellotushy.com
church right now to save 10 that's
hellotushy.com
church right now to save 10 percent the
show is also brought to you by onit.com
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to save 10 on all of their amazing
optimization products like alpha brand
new mood stream tech immune and shroom
tech sport
kick that [ __ ]
it's that time
little wednesday night action
before austin texas the [ __ ]
red eye
packed and ready
guns are packed
the mule is on the way
and you got the church of what's
happening now [ __ ]
wednesday august 14th
september 14th
are you kidding me or what
get the cough medicine out [ __ ]
we're going deep tonight
dip that joint in some formaldehyde
it's the church of what's happening now
baby
giggly
[ __ ] tremendous
you know what that song was overplayed
when i was young and i got that it's
still overplayed and i heard it today
because usually when it comes on i just
switch it i just switch it's one of
those you just switch
well i heard it today and i'm like jesus
[ __ ] christ sometimes you go a long
time without hearing one of the ones you
get sick of a lot of beatles songs are
like that you get sick of hearing them
because they're always played if you're
out in a lot of places but then if you
don't hear for a long time then here
you're like
beetle fan
uh
i would not describe my i like the
beatles i wouldn't describe myself as
like a beat like don barris is a huge
beatles fan now my mom is a huge [ __ ]
you know albums like when you were
dinner of course and she put on [ __ ]
let let it be
all the songs on the album yep my
sister's a huge beatles fan i like the
beatles i wouldn't say i'm a huge i grew
up hating the beatles because
the people around me
that's all the [ __ ] they talked about
that i'm a more your side and
i
then
all i always liked paul mccarthy solo
and i liked john lennon solo and then i
just went backwards and there's an album
that switches for me once it's really
guitare
like early on i don't like none of that
[ __ ] yeah they have two albums like 66
to 60 whatever
it's garbage for me yeah the second half
of their career when they got the
treasure i like that they started doing
acid and all that stuff yeah that was
that blew my phone like yeah i want to
hold your hand days yeah i don't want to
hit i don't want that [ __ ]
what's up buddy what's going on my
little goomba each of that i'm feeling
good getting ready for austin texas
barbecue oh yeah [ __ ] banana cream
pie with the wafers in it
[ __ ] seafood gumbo hondui sausage
wow
shrimp and crab meat lobster i feel like
now you're just naming food shrimp and
crab meat
salad with a blue cheese dressing on it
are you [ __ ] kidding me with big
country texas [ __ ] tomatoes in that
[ __ ]
oh yeah i'm going deep they said to take
you to papacino somebody hit me today
with an email on twitter and said make
sure you take him to papa [ __ ] see
those
he'll [ __ ] write paul a letter right
there while he's eating it
i can't wait
and then i had something kind of [ __ ]
up happened last night what nothing
really [ __ ] up but like okay i always
try to be safe so whenever i take an
edible like i try to wait pretty much
like until i'm sober to go home
but even when you're sober
like sometimes the next morning the
freeway gets a little bit creepy for me
so i actually got off like three exits
too early last night and just took the
side streets home because the freeway
was too much
because you were too stoned and i wasn't
even that stoned i was like it was like
six hours ago and i had like two stars
it wasn't that bad it was just there's
times i've taken edibles in the morning
like an [ __ ] before a flight
and i've gotten in that [ __ ] car and
you're in that little hiv lane
lane yeah and you're hiv you're
boogieing and you're coming next to cars
by an inch you start getting creepy
after the tent sure like if you take a
star or you eat another balloon you get
on the 405 it gets [ __ ] up oh my god
we did it one time and we were driving
we i don't remember nothing we blacked
out the san diego trip it took there was
an hour in that in that trip
but i [ __ ] blacked out you don't
remember it i was too high my eyes were
wigging out that this the the the lights
were [ __ ] affecting my eyes that's
the night i got sick we were going down
the hill right yeah you just yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
dog i can't handle that [ __ ] either do
you either of you remember the first
time when you came when you were driving
on the freeway in los angeles and you
had the realization that it's legal for
motorcycles to go zoom in through the
lanes oh yeah like that's extremely
illegal in like chicago or indiana or
any place i've lived in the past and
you're just sitting there and
gridlock traffic and these motorcycles
go zoom in like 30 miles an hour in
between the lanes
how the hell is that legal it's so
dangerous it was
i remember like when i first moved here
i lived in the valley because it was
cheap and i was always lit working down
there
and
i would always go down to 405
and one morning i think like the first
week i was there i got
i got kicked by one because like
apparently they didn't like where i was
in the lane or something so as they went
by they kicked my car you got to pay
attention to the rear view mirror oh my
god constantly yeah
if you're in the hov or in the fourth
lane you have to pay attention
constantly in los angeles very seldom do
they go in lane number one or two or
three unless they're coming on but even
when they come on they shoot right for
the hiv and they [ __ ] shoot down that
[ __ ] and i'll tell you there's
times you're just sitting there in
traffic and you don't know
what have you got to cut over and you
don't see this guy he's dead felicia
michael saw a guy die on the 101 or 170
sunday morning doing 90.
doing that on a motorcycle bam yeah with
nobody out there bam just [ __ ] win
that
what i found out about your recently
people that i did not know yes sir is
that you're such a big sports guy i
thought that you were like the [ __ ]
third wheel on the show i listened to
you a couple weeks ago oh yeah
you're [ __ ] knowledgeable on sports
thank you buddy yeah i uh well you know
this is my 12th season working at the
red zone
uh for the nfl and i pretty much have
worked my way to head of research so
especially when it comes to football ufc
and football are my two
favorites no baseball i like the cubs i
like baseball baseball's probably a
little bit after nba i would go
probably nfl ufc
nba baseball and hockey are probably
tied for whatever
all this soccer [ __ ] everybody's
talking i know you gotta we all have
these international fans they constantly
hit us up you guys need to talk about
european soccer more i'm like i got too
much on the plate to start watching when
you want to grow up how old are you now
i'll be 44 friday okay happy birthday
thank you brother i'm not 10 years old
and what a lot of people should know is
that when i was in high school
there was no sucker
only spanish kids that didn't speak
english played soccer on saturdays at
the park you think i'm kidding you there
was no soccer there's no soccer there
was a tennis team
in my high school and archery
but there was no sanika archery shot
until somebody got shot with an app i
was just gonna say somebody got shot in
an arrow in high school in archery and
that was the end of that [ __ ] course
i know i never understood like the it's
just i understand why people like it but
it's just too long like what soccer yeah
it's just too much well it's just for me
to watch something it's for three hours
and then it's zero to zero i'm just like
somebody do something somebody do
something i always bust these balls
about sports on sunday to sit there for
12 hours and eat wings and [ __ ]
you're a big sports guy i i used to be i
used to be he's always he i love that i
love he's not as big as i [ __ ]
thought he was like there's times i'll
ask him questions about it and he'll go
i'm not watching because the new england
patriots aren't in it so [ __ ] it
i thought he would watch everything but
i have friends that grew up watching
everything so i learned to watch
everything i would get i had no home so
i would get stuck at corki's watching
all those [ __ ] games all day making
believe i was having a good time praying
and get the [ __ ] out of that right and
i'll never forget i bust these balls one
time i went to a car sales convention
and they had different guys talking
about their careers and how
they became dealers and all this [ __ ]
like a corporate gig and kind of thing
you mean no it wasn't i wasn't a
comedian i was selling cars at the time
oh okay you would the dealer would send
you
okay for a day to a seminar and
you spoke about sales and whatever the
[ __ ] and there was one particular guy
his name was doug spending
and
he said two things that always like
[ __ ] with me he goes
when you have money you have to know how
much money you have at all times which i
don't have money so it doesn't really
matter right but he was like uh the guy
in the casino in ocean's eleven how do
you guys see it that every hour somebody
would give him a piece of paper
with what they made what was in the bank
at that time remember i was telling you
lee that he was like an old-school jew
right doug's betting and he said that
you know every hour on the hour i know
exactly what i got in the bank my
assistant brings me a card
and i put it in the top and all day when
i get home i put them in a paper clip
and you know this is and then towards
the end
we were standing around and then there's
a big sports team very big like a big
[ __ ] bronco thing we were talking
about during the broncos in denver you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want if
you're going to do a crime it's during
the bronco game sure
what are we talking about
crime in denver oh yeah yeah you were
talking about how you i don't know you
[ __ ] so awesome you know you said
that yeah
car convention bunch of guys were
standing around doug spreading
and they were talking about the [ __ ]
broncos
broncos this broncos that
and somebody said to him what do you
think about the [ __ ] percentages of
whatever
and he goes
you know i don't know much about the
broncos i'm a friend of elways and i go
to the games i'm a fan of this because i
really don't know the numbers he goes i
i
i don't have a memory for useless
information
and i felt so [ __ ] bad at that time
and i started thinking about i was like
a young man i always liked sports sure
like but at that time i wasn't really
like i was the type of kid that went to
a baseball game with a bat in a glove
i went to see the next one of basketball
one of those [ __ ] [ __ ] sure of
course so
one day i just realized you got to make
a living
and sometimes if you want to make a
living you can't watch college football
day on a saturday sure and once you do
it it's very liberating it's like
throwing away your iphone
yeah i can see you you follow me you
know i can see where you're going like
weekend six
your girlfriend's at a park
and here you are with six gorillas
yeah [ __ ] potato chips farting like
me yeah smelling up a room you know and
at one point you gotta go wait a second
yeah i remember one year i went i did
that kind of throw away your iphone
thing with football uh because you know
the team i was rooting for and had bet
on was eliminated out of the playoffs
and i was like so now it's afc nfc
championship weekend so this you know
there's one game then there's another
game and those are the two teams that go
to the super bowl then it's a week off
then it's super bowl so it's the
second and third most important games of
the year other than the super bowl and
i'm like [ __ ] man i'm not gonna watch
football i mean my girlfriend went to
well i went with her friends we went to
magic mountain
and it was just like same thing you're
saying like committing a crime at a
broncos home game there was [ __ ] and
i hate lines so i never want to go to
amusement parks there was nobody at this
thing like the roller coaster we would
ride would just pull into the thing and
they'd be like if you want to stay on it
stay on it if you want to get off get
off like you i you never had to wait in
lines because everybody was watching
those two games that's a good idea
because honestly like it like joey was
saying like if the patriots don't make
it to the super bowl this year i don't
really give it like i honestly that's
crazy don't i would like if i was if i
followed the giants yeah do you have a
favorite like
yeah
are you kind of a broncos guy i mean
let's take it to the beginning uh-huh
i like the [ __ ] suits i like the
uniforms when i was a kid when i came on
the minnesota vikings i like the colors
and i tried to watch them but they were
losers they lost like four super bowls
so i had i couldn't hang out with the
vikings no more
then one day i was watching football
i was watching the dallas cowboys and i
saw them do that thing they do in the
offense
when they first line up they come up and
their hands are up and then
the guy would go huh and then they'd set
their [ __ ] hands uh-huh and they had
their home colors on which their home
colors are badass i think it's the
silver in those days it was the silver
with the blue [ __ ] things and the
[ __ ] blue
so i became a dallas fan like i like
dallas i like that style of
football and then i liked uh
once lawrence taylor became a giant i
loved it i loved it everybody everybody
liked that guy i would have liked to
watch him and that was like probably the
end of the coke
i mean players get busted for coke and
all this kind of stuff now but back then
like sterile strawberry all those guys
that it was such a big
thing in the 80s
that ever for everyone from wall street
to the you know all the way down was
doing coke that it wasn't really like if
we knew now if somebody was in the nfl
doing as much coke as lawrence taylor
was back then
i mean you
he'd be done he would play four or five
games he would piss dirty he wouldn't be
able to piss clean again and he would
just be gone we never would if they had
the same drug testing system they do now
in the nfl we never would have seen the
greatness of lawrence taylor
that's crazy i don't think they were
prepared for
the epidemic they endured it wasn't
remember before lawrence taylor
there was a guy by the name of hollywood
henderson yeah that played for the
dallas cowboys sergio ortega
a [ __ ] listener of this podcast this
beauty and the beast sent me the
my one of my favorite reads of all time
is playboy
october of
81 they put an article about about
hollywood henderson uncle henderson was
done at that time and they put a [ __ ]
article out he starts from training camp
in tarzana
when the cowboys used to training camp
up here there's still somewhere there's
still an auction already
that's right that's right
he goes here i am at rookie training
camp i got two hits acid
three joints four cigarettes
forty dollars worth of blood i mean he
just described what he had uh i don't
think i'm gonna make it for three weeks
you know that was towards the end of his
career or earlier that was when he was a
rookie and then just gets from there it
just he's right what he was doing with
no money yeah he's renting cars he's
going to the comedy store and picking up
the uh richard pryor and then they would
go pick up the pointer sisters and they
would go free based cocaine really oh my
god the [ __ ] article is just
sensational
and he talks about how uh ed two tall
jones for his
birthday got him four women the black
one a brunette a blonde and a [ __ ]
redhead
like that's how crazy dallas was
then the [ __ ] the the biggest shock
of the 80s was the san diego chargers
they had a quarterback named dan phelps
and i always talk about this i always
think about life like this that
dan thoughts was built like lee do you
remember damn of course yeah he was
built like lee handsome [ __ ] but
he could throw a [ __ ] ball yeah from
here to your mother's house and back
and so eric coryell was the coach they
they called him air corrio because he
always went to the air
but he also had a running back called
chuck muncie mm-hmm remember in check
once he became a coke snorting
[ __ ] so years later they came
out with books you got to hunt these
books down about what was really going
on in san diego when they played miami
in miami oh yeah play off when kellen
winslow kellen winslow yeah yeah when
they had to walk them off the field with
[ __ ] two guys and then all of a
sudden you see them back there in
[ __ ] the fourth quarter and you're
like what the [ __ ] how they lost but
they stayed in miami for a week and
bought a half a kilo and
they were nuts
they were nuts as a team what lawrence
taylor was doing by himself in new york
the san diego chargers were doing in san
diego it was so bad that fred dean
the all-star defensive end raised his
hand demanded to be traded he got traded
to the san francisco 49ers they ended up
winning check it out with fred dean and
one of the quotes he told him he goes
why did you leave san diego it was a
bunch of freebasing [ __ ] really
oh my god hilarious they went deep so
the deepest one was that one sunday
night one sunday nfl your show comes on
and goes tragic news out of san diego
dan thoughts fell down the scares
vacuuming and he hurt his shoulder years
later they were snorting blow
they were paranoid they had founds had a
gun
and the gun slipped and shot him in the
[ __ ] shoulder they had a liaison to
the police department they called him
and he swept it all under the [ __ ]
tank like uh in those days you had one
cop you called listen you stab a [ __ ]
you would be great at that job what's
that is the like the the cleaner the
cleaner like the guy that's in uh what's
that show on showtime ray ray donovan
that kind of job i think you would be
good at that well yeah because you got
to be around the spot like but that [ __ ]
takes too long
the people today don't listen
i can't if i go to leave ten times lean
the count's gonna be in two minutes shut
your [ __ ] mouth the attorney comes
here within 10 minutes leo be talking
because he's a sweetheart of a guy just
like my wife
they're too nice to understand that
concept all right give me another check
keep your [ __ ] match
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut you'll be
my don't even say a word when you go to
jail
don't talk to no when they come over and
sit next to you and ask you what are you
in there for and you have drugs that's
the [ __ ] snitch
don't say two words
but people don't listen i didn't listen
so i get it yeah i didn't listen and i
came from there
i can't right you follow me i can't
imagine people who didn't come from
there it's very hard oh yeah and when
you talk to them later why'd you say
something well they scared me i told you
not to say a [ __ ] word
but today it's it's different lee
doesn't know the ropes
only people get even after i beat it
into you the first time the first time
after you get it's like anything else
yeah once you get kicked on the stomach
then you'll learn oh yeah once you learn
that everything you say is gonna really
be held against you and you're you're
gonna drop your jaw you're gonna go
i was just kidding
i just saw something when a guy said
that
he fainted oh it was a show about a
hooker's thing in florida just a
disgusting show i was watching
about a month ago i was in denver and
one night i got back to the hotel room
and there's a show on about [ __ ] uh
undercovers things oh sure those and not
and they were really a cop and then as
soon as you give me money
oh and they got the camera set up
cameras set up like that and it was
hysterical the cops came in the guy's
like oh my god i feel dizzy he was like
and i remember right he was here on a
visitation visa and he goes
oh my god i'd feel dizzy
and then like sit sitting there gave him
water and he sit there and also he just
looks at the window and the cop goes why
do you keep looking at the window he
goes
because my family's going to be very
upset
i
i feel like jumping out the window at
this point in my life and the cop goes
you're suicidal so i put him in a
[ __ ] cell for three days you know no
[ __ ] shoelaces just for saying that
the guy was livid he's like it was just
an expression i just said it was enough
and he did he just said there's a
[ __ ] expression but yeah joe gentile
they could do whatever the [ __ ] they
want to you man if you when push comes
to shove if somebody
at power wants to make you [ __ ]
vanish you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
what a crazy [ __ ] world we live
living really is crazy
i'm sick of all these people
have you listened or heard of all this
colin kaepernick [ __ ] of everyone's
whether he takes a knee during the
national anthem whether he doesn't when
he's like who gives a [ __ ] even if you
want to protest it's your right to
protest a bunch of players are taking
these
he was and what does that mean
he means what they were they're
in essence not refusing to stand during
the national anthem but they are
protesting during the national anthem
all of
the uh racial abuse that's been going on
from cops all the videos that are coming
out there you know that's kind of a lot
of them taking their stance to that
and then espn is eating it up like it's
a soap opera
and then like the the nate boyer who we
had on here uh like a year or two ago he
went and talked to kaepernick i read and
that's that he they came up with the
knee thing is what i read because
apparently it's a little bit more
respectful they felt like it was more
respectful than uh sitting down
so that's what they're doing apparently
how are you interested
but it's uh
hold up um
oh you guys i mean you guys talking
about they can do whatever they want and
i don't know that much about it but i've
i read a couple articles dude like they
speci supposedly had like secret jails
like there was one in chicago
i'm not sure they do like have you heard
of any of that stuff joey like
all my life man
really
oh my [ __ ] life [ __ ]
like not secret jails but every jail has
a room that nobody knows about
every jail has a room that doesn't have
a camera
every jail has a sector that doesn't
have a camera that the camera can't
reach
they do that purposely
they do that purposely but what happens
to the tape it's there well what do you
see i see him and him talking and going
into the hallway sorry charlie
there's always something that
they could
there's a way for them to get around it
and abuse their power yeah is that what
i want to say yeah uh-huh you know
there's always somewhere on the walk to
the shower where i could get hit with a
stick in the prison
there's one [ __ ] opening whenever you
watch anything on tv about a prisoner
what do they say we'll get them
after the mess hall there's no guards
there
that they know is there's always an out
it's so [ __ ] weird that it makes you
think the [ __ ] it makes you become a
computer as a conspiracy theorist like
there's always enough there always is
there always is a [ __ ] slip up so
you know and all the like this
conspiracy theories and
i'm just i i don't care
i just get to i'm like well
so maybe we didn't land on the moon
maybe aliens really exist maybe all this
what does it [ __ ] mean who care it's
not like you're ever gonna find out it's
interesting
but it's something that you think about
when you're in a flight
yeah in between a book and a movie not
even not even for me not you know you
look at the kennedy assassination you
look at the moon landing you look at
this you look at that you look at the
it's all gotta by the way if you're
gonna sit there and dedicate your life
to this it's gonna eat you up alive you
just move forward and worry about your
little circle
like this with your arms you see that
little hug right there that circle
that's yours if anybody interferes that
circle that's you have to worry there's
a circle like this you got a basket in
front of you you know that's it yeah if
i'm gonna sit here and sit here for an
hour and debate the kelly it's been done
what 50 [ __ ] years who gives a [ __ ]
50 [ __ ] years this has been a
thousand movies they've there's been so
many movies they've remastered the
movies and made more [ __ ] money and
joe schmoke keeps buying this [ __ ] like
it really [ __ ] matters like we don't
know how the movie is going to end you
know now what do we have we have a
thousand conspiracies against the 9 11.
and i tell you i've heard some valid
[ __ ] points maybe but what do you
want me to do exactly if you don't
[ __ ] open this up
it would be very shocking
to me if a country would put their own
people up to get blown up but it's been
done before my problem my problem is i'm
too gullible
because i like it with some good editing
i believe you look gullible i i do
doesn't he look gullible i look like i'd
be and i am you look like you're easily
swindled what have you learned how long
have you been in this town me yes i have
been here
for one year did i get like
17 years that's right we did the porno
thing together the pool was [ __ ] we did
i forgot yeah we talked about that last
time
was that 97 98 that had to be like
i must have just got here just got here
let me talk to you about something
you're now this guy
you we were talking before the podcast
started about
i don't have ten i don't have one book
in me i have ten but one of them pertain
to what we've seen here
and a lot of it has been positive what i
would write in my book is the growth of
people
what i've seen people who when i got
here were uh assistant agents and now
they run a comedy division i see them
and they give me a big hug
i still remember them being young
walking around the comedy store all
[ __ ] nervous you see those people now
you see those people now so
if you come to me now as a 26 year old i
don't like my job at gersch i don't like
my job at william morris you know i'm
sorry i'm like listen sit tight because
i've seen something here those guys that
were getting coffee [ __ ] when i got
here those guys that were out every
night with the agent laughing at their
jokes and going no he's not yeah you're
right he's not funny yeah those guys
today
are running this town running [ __ ] the
guy from caa there's another guy from
joe whatever
like four of those guys that were
assistants back then
are now running comedy divisions yeah
and they were 20 then and now they're
whatever 21 22 then and now they're in
their 40s and you see them with
maseratis and you're like damn
i saw this guy when he [ __ ] you know
when he was doing nothing you know bobby
lee tells a story about him and i get
being broke at the latino life festival
1999
we were so broke that we had to have a
manager buyers dinner because they
didn't give you a per diem
you know you see
uh comedy routine people who were
supposed to be stars
and didn't become stars but the main
thing i wanted to talk to you about that
really makes you think and i want the
public to really know about this the
people who listen to this show
we deal with
i don't know how many comedians
in our circle but maybe
i wasn't gonna say let's just say
hundreds yeah yeah yeah
and there's a lot of funny and i'm not
here to put anybody down i'm just here
to educate somebody and to talk to
uh jason's good about this stuff
so now we have a a thousand comedians
and every year out of those thousand
comedians
uh 18 of them get a special from comedy
central
so these are the 18 they choose team
there's these other comedians that are
working hard that don't have a manager
an agent sure and just don't know how to
get there and they're hilarious it's
like the people who are too [ __ ]
stupid to get to a big college and they
go to community college and they
transfer when they get their [ __ ]
together now they go to lead the nba in
scoring but for the first two years of
college they would they were [ __ ]
playing with crayons and sharpening
pencils and
lighting fires and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
writing on dixie cups and [ __ ] their
name right same thing it's the same
[ __ ] concept
but think about the people who have
never gotten those specials who are
really funny that the public doesn't
know about us there's so many so you
have to think
that the same way comedy is judgmental
you have to think that
the media news is judgmental the stories
they report absolutely you have to
assume that when we listened to led
zeppelin there was really three led
zeppelins we never really listened to
because maybe they were on heroin maybe
they didn't look right maybe they were
all fat and they didn't have the long
hair and the look yeah you know how now
they'll say uh they're looking for guys
who never has it that's me jason t
jason uh they're looking for guys
between 27 and 34 and you're like
they're looking for funny yeah but but
no they're looking for a demographic you
don't fit it you're out yeah you're out
you're dead meat so the same way i and
i'm not putting down comedy central cnn
or anything like that i'm just making an
observation that if you think about what
they do with comedians out of all the
great comics that are around us the ones
that get chosen for certain things and
and we're not hating
but you sit there and go is it this guy
got this oh there's a lie and this guy
is the [ __ ] king of that and he
didn't even talk to him about this right
it must be frustrating from a certain
point because
i'm one of those people i grew up in
boston there's not
and i grew up outside of boston so all i
grew up watching was pre premium blend
like that was when i was growing up all
those things so those are the people you
want to see and then when you have a
choice to go see if you're looking at
the schedule at the improv and you see
someone who you know that you'd like
their special versus jason tebow or joey
diaz who you don't know their names
you're going to pick the person who you
know you like
sure
yeah that's why a lot of us covet those
you know getting those tv spots getting
those things because now you're selling
out in some towns where they probably
wouldn't even let you feature
and your act hasn't changed and your act
hasn't changed your act hasn't changed
one single bit from the time your tv
thing airs you know
you know if you're gonna be like uh on
some sort of sitcom or something you
know it premieres tonight you're you're
a selling out headliner
in two weeks later and your act hasn't
changed one bit whether you're good or
bad
you know there's terrible terrible
headliners in this country that
get to headline for decent pay
that are just headlining because they're
on xyz who gives a [ __ ] show but you
know that doesn't work for a long time
nope because it's a perishable product
we're putting out
listen there's guys that have a certain
air or confidence to them and it's like
in any profession any profession like if
let's say
me and lee were welders and we welded
for some shipyard in long beach but
guess what well he's a great welder for
a 28 year old guy he's [ __ ] brilliant
but you know what
i welded in vietnam with missiles
getting shot at me so i'm always going
to get hired over [ __ ] leave because
if this [ __ ] gets harry i gotta be
anomaly what have you been shooting i'm
saying like yeah yeah there's always
that extra experience for years lee made
it asked a question about were we ever
frustrated but
you get frustrated you learn the ropes
and then you realize that
every [ __ ] year every [ __ ] year
five guys pop up
one because he was on a reality show
one because uh
just who knows random situations sure
and all of a sudden there was a
situation 15 years ago
where a guy was in the first [ __ ]
ever reality show
you were a kid
when reality first started there was
fear factor something else and something
else but there was one show that was
like a guy who married a chick
like the first bachelor
that guy was a [ __ ] comedian who was
flaggery whatever you call it like he
was at the end
he wasn't doing much he only worked like
10 weeks a year
late he got huge
so what they did
who is it i forget his name and i had
just worked with him in portland's at
harvey's in portland like maybe a year
before i moved here from seattle
i just worked on him met him he was a
nice guy
and he was telling me that he was he
already on the show then or was he no
okay i came down here and all of a
sudden one day everybody's talking about
i remember that comic they thought yeah
oh my god and he was on there and his
popularity built
and all of a sudden what they did was
great story just to show you that you
have to have balls in every angle what
they did was at that time
who's the guy that died
robert
what they did was they had robert
schimmel and all the improvs thursday
friday saturday and sunday
so what did they do this guy got such a
big demand that they cut into
everybody's schedule on the improv
jason tebow no more thursday
the guy from the bats is covered in
mm-hmm
you know and you lost but jason he was
putting you know asses and scenes he was
putting 400 [ __ ] seats in every
market they had him out from monday to
sunday
for eight months
he didn't build it so
it went into pizza at all you know and
this guy was an old school like he had
bricks he had uh chops yeah they stay in
the business sure he had chops
but he never carried the [ __ ] he never
covered the spread a lot of the
last comic standing a lot of the guys
that one last comic standing at first
were feature acts absolutely two weeks
later they were on the road dog getting
five g's
headlining and just they can't do it
and they can't do 25. they gotta call
gene pompa and all these alternate
comics to fill in the time yeah they
also did the same with my buddy from uh
the one who [ __ ] stabs himself in the
eyeballs and [ __ ] oh stevo stevo i
actually you know yeah with steve yes
great guy but when stevo started at
least he was getting on stage and he
built it he would bring two guys with
him to do
30 yeah and he would do 35 38 and now
he's doing an hour he taped the [ __ ]
special so you know what like a guy like
that
he's a cool guy he's a cool guy really
because he gets that and he understood
that and he used to um when he first
started doing that and he's like well
now i'm getting paid to headline but i'm
not really a comic like what am i going
to do
and
you know he
he paid me to he would just watch he
would record video recorded sets
and he would do 35 40 he would do
everything he could and he'd like come
over to my place we're going to watch
the watch my set and i want you to just
like as a comic like help me punch stuff
up help me stretch stuff out you know
like and dude we did that for
i don't know five six months or
something
that's one thing that when i first got
here i lacked this confidence
but i saw myself in [ __ ] up situations
every night
like it's like for me going to jiu jitsu
now when i go to jiu jitsu there's a
part of the class where you warm up
there's a part of the class where you
drill and there's a part of the class
where you have to break a guard
ever since i've been in this advanced
class i haven't broken one guard
i guess not only do they [ __ ] sweep
me they submit me i'm [ __ ] terrible
at it yeah that's what happened with
county okay
everywhere i went i had to follow don
pereira
paul mooney i was always in the dungeon
carlos mencia like i went to the lab
factory latino night everybody who
walked in
was there to crush me pablo paul
rodriguez and then i had to follow him
so for a long time my confidence was
crushed what i didn't know is
i was getting killed when i was figuring
out ways how to get a little out of
binds
so for the first couple times i went on
stage yeah i didn't get a laugh but then
i started figuring out how to get a
laugh at the eight-minute mark the
12-minute mark yeah i laugh before i get
off i learned how to improvise a little
bit and get out of my [ __ ] joke get
the [ __ ] out of the joke then what what
you got eight people you're bombing and
you're still gonna you're still gonna do
that [ __ ] material that's killing
your goal go walk right and you learn
and also you learn how to get yourself
out of blinds and comedy that's the
beauty of it that's what a lot of people
can't do you know sometimes we're up on
stage when we say something that's
[ __ ] up we lose them for a couple
minutes last night told the story about
robbing a chick in l.a one time
i fingered and whatever she had money in
her [ __ ] pocket oh trump and you
could see the tone of the room change
right but the 20 year experience knows
how to talk through that yes and how to
say one word to change the momentum one
word something sweet something lovable
something will change that whole [ __ ]
thing around i remember
i saw something brilliant once
a movie came out called
what's the more rich again andy garcia
when they [ __ ] like dirty cops oh
89 90.
richard gere was so big
he was in every 80s thing what is it
internal affair
you ever see that movie yeah no no why
would you like
hey you're busy watching the purple is
yellow
whatever the [ __ ] that dumb show is but
uh
personally
you know this guy had just one whatever
the [ __ ] it is this guy had just won
i think he won the academy award for
office in the gentleman can you check
that out for me if you want okay if you
won an academy award for that that was
like the biggest [ __ ] he did uh
american gigolo which yeah he was big he
got like a brand five yeah that was
[ __ ] badass then he dropped something
else
then he dropped
uh
officer the [ __ ] gentleman and he was
just huge
and then somewhere you know i don't know
his itinerary of films i'm not johnny
imdb
but somewhere he dropped internal
affairs
and internal affairs
he played somebody
that was just a complete
scumbag
but the beauty of it was
he was a cop yeah lee there's a scene
where he goes to his ex-wife to give him
money for support okay
and he's like i ain't been good you know
when he's like so what are you doing
right now
and she's like nothing i'm just gonna
wait for the kids he goes he just opens
up the bedroom and opens the [ __ ]
door like it's time to [ __ ] [ __ ]
he had eight girlfriends in this [ __ ]
movie lee
he was just filthy
he killed his partner
i mean you [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
uh cheered for him at the end you know
and then
he came out with pretty women right away
and he changed your perception you
forgot all about internal affairs it was
the most brilliant move i haven't
[ __ ] seen in my life i don't think
richard you won an oscar no i don't
think so either the movie one
somebody want to [ __ ] ask in that
movie something happened but who gives a
[ __ ] she won one for that for a pretty
woman didn't she
did julie roberts win somebody i think
she won one for that and i think
uh
officer and the gentleman maybe won one
i don't think he got it but i think that
movie won you guys are talking about
something very interesting somewhere the
conversation changed
so hollywood henderson did his damage
and when i was in high school when i had
quit in 81
i had heard about this guy lawrence
taylor and one night it's thanksgiving
and my friend was supposed to pick me up
we're going into harlem to pick up an
eight ball and whatever
and i'm watching lawrence taylor on the
outside with a white jersey on 56 and
his fingers are moving
and he's got his left leg up first and
he's ready to block and also he face
like he's gonna go in and the
quarterback takes the ball and
immediately looks to his left and just
throws a pass in the three-yard line
also you see lawrence taylor scooping
and running back to 97 yards on
thanksgiving day
my head blew up i'm a defense guy i like
people flying and throwing [ __ ] balls
and [ __ ]
but i'm a defensive guy sure lawrence
taylor sucked me in but then i started
hearing things
like i was out copping and i would hear
about it you were in new york i didn't
know you're running i'm in new york
that's where you were i'm in new york at
this run sure so 83 there was a party
for z 100.
that's a radio station or a radio
station and that's the first time i
heard anything jason t but also i hear
these girls from my hometown went
and they came back and their heads were
blown you're not going to believe it
everybody had blow leonard marshall
marshall [ __ ] lawrence taylor
and i'm like no
lawrence taylor does not do coke like at
first i got like a mat and then i go but
now you you're no i'm doing cover yeah
i'm [ __ ] so why were you shocked
because he was one of my heroes oh cause
you had him on him yeah i had him on
your head so it's like julia's serving i
find out he's a woman being nothing yeah
julia serving as a saint all his life
he's never done a [ __ ] thing except
his son was a junkie but then his fault
sometimes you gotta give one together
so uh
when lawrence taylor started going
around i started hearing
little stories and then i moved to
colorado
and that winter
i'm hearing stories that not only are
the [ __ ]
uh
the giants buy and blow and stuff but
they're hanging out in the bar i was
hanging out with and they would lock the
door and take it out
and snort let it marshal a couple of
white dudes and at this time my friend
was a ball boy for the nets and he's
selling coke to daryl dawkins
and daryl dawkins is giving him a
sneaker so he could sell them after the
game to make more coke money [ __ ]
tremendous [ __ ] stories because they
get new pair of sneakers for everybody
every game yeah i didn't know that they
usually give them a way to say they give
them away yeah yeah not this guy not
daryl dawkins he was giving up the
[ __ ] whatever this kid name was noel
noel would sell him
he would sign them just crazy [ __ ]
so i left and that winter i was hearing
all these rumblings
so i come back february of 84
and i'm i'm just i go from [ __ ] being
a saint like not really i'm not gonna
lie to you i was at least trying to sure
and then by the summer it was everywhere
cocaine was everywhere it was to the
point where lee was selling coke like
lee would call me up and go listen my
neighbor came over here and asked me if
i know anything about cocaine i know you
like it so i got you some really lee
yeah
[ __ ] lee man i'll be right over how
much did you get me i don't know he said
it was two pounds two point two pounds
of g though and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
what the [ __ ] that's how it got
because people were getting it at one
point in 84 was it was everywhere it was
like the weed stores now i always
compare it to the growth of the wheat
store that's interesting and
scarface is [ __ ] ripping it it's on
it's on vcr now and everybody's at home
watching scarface every time he says
[ __ ] that dude a line of coke it was out
the summer of 84 you got scarface you
got michael jackson you got bruce
springsteen born in the usa you got
michael and you got blow everywhere and
everybody's selling it and the most
unlikely people
are [ __ ] selling blow uh-huh and
people are saying to you like joey can
you get rid of this i don't know i'll
ask tebow
weren't people really doing it
it wasn't as secretive right like
because
it wasn't as bad for you
at that point nobody was really there
was a few ads that said uh i lost my job
i lost my house
i lost my car i gave let's party exactly
yeah all right
we're going out it went from a white
collar right by 85 people were already
fighting it yeah they were fighting
[ __ ] the colombians pablo escobar it
was on but on the streets of new york
city
miami yeah you know anyway you went you
get coke in five [ __ ] minutes
and i had friends that were like i'm
telling you guys that worked for the
town of north bergen that were like
plumbers
they were calling me up and going dog
can you come over here i guess the
neighbor's colombian
and he wanted me to ask if anybody could
he he gave me a lens yeah take it and
i'll go you [ __ ] serious and it
wasn't just [ __ ] it was real 1984
yeah i still got ready yeah i i only
because i was so young back then
uh you know 84 so i was probably like 6
15 14 something like that back then i
never had like big coke runs i never had
you know back then but it was definitely
around i remember my father doing coke i
remember all his friends doing coke and
that whole scene by the time like i'm
like
old enough to be [ __ ] around with
drugs or anything like that the weed was
already coming it was already starting
to be weed
you know it was before
you know then there was that whole
ecstasy that was a quick thing everybody
doing ecstasy was it felt like a i think
that's just like a young person's drug
all that stuff just evolved listen my
quaalude
became their ecstasy totally right then
ecstasy became dmh and this became this
but it's here so here you go my
attorney's it was valium value so
october of 84 i'm gone tebow
and me and my friends went to a giant
game to watch the tampa bay buccaneers
against the giants with a running back
called james wilder okay i don't even
remember that was a beautiful [ __ ]
man he could run the ball
lawrence taylor's at the top of his
[ __ ] game
okay at that point october everybody
knew listen
listen here's the plan dawg
lawrence taylor what do you want to do
right you got two options you block and
you play the rest of the field and you
throw away from him and you run away
from him or you can run at him
both ways you're going to lose yeah both
ways he's going to figure it out by the
second quarter and you're going to be
buried and that game i saw something
that i had never seen before like it
taught me about life
tampa bay said we're going to tell you
what we're going to [ __ ] he
snorted the entire 43-yard line no no
champion but he came out and he goes
give me the [ __ ] ball and i'm gonna
run it right at lawrence nobody's ever
done that before
nobody's ever done it let's try it
it worked
he cracked lauren's tail and what
[ __ ] me up after that is
nobody ever caught that
because lawrence taylor was always
chasing
nobody ever went at him
they went at him i'm telling you he was
probably shocked at that too every play
was down lawrence taylor's mouth yeah
right you know what we're gonna give it
to you yeah you want to run the outside
he's gonna be running there and laura's
lawrence taylor kind of sort of
and i learned something even about life
just go go
and i'll never forget that game so now i
go crazy
i try to get my life together i stop
doing blow
i have a friend who a house burns down
house burned down like half of it burnt
down
so the insurance company those days put
you in a hotel right and they put her up
it could be a marriott
i'm too old now i used to know the name
then
it could have been a [ __ ] marriott it
could have been a hilton but anyway this
place
had the best happy hour at the time what
city is this it was in lindhurst new
jersey okay okay
lynn hurst put a town next to it and
they pretty much and you're hearing this
from joey diaz i'm a fat [ __ ] they
invented the happy hour at that time
yeah uh the ground round had the [ __ ]
monday night football game with the
meatballs and the wings and [ __ ] but
this place gave it to you for gratis on
the arm and i'm talking about
glazed wings on leland swim i like
barbecue they had that they had wings
they had meatloaf they had pot roast
mashed potatoes people would [ __ ] uh
uh you know caterers with [ __ ] suits
on giving you food
so this girl tells me she goes you gotta
come
the giants are downstairs oh [ __ ] get
down there every [ __ ] night
come i get to the hotel at the time i'm
trying to be clean and so i'm slowing
down and she's staying there just
because she's gonna put her up her and
her mom got two separate rooms
and she's a [ __ ] nut she's a [ __ ]
the real dear holy feel it's 1985 i'm 22
years old maybe 201.
i'm the real dear holyfield i'm just
looking for a gun or an envelope to end
up in jail
and i end up going over there one day
and they're all there the knicks are
there cool and the gang is there
cool in the game oh my god because
they're all from jersey
so it's a it's a priority it's a
predominantly black bar
that was connected to the hotel it was
no it was in the hotel like this was a
hotel bar you know this was the [ __ ]
spot yeah
from five to nine every night nobody
knew
this is where everybody who everybody
went to the city looking for these guys
were here right the lyndhurst sheridan
nobody knew about the lindhurst [ __ ]
sheridan i get a call i get down there
lyndhurst sheridan is rocking and
[ __ ] rolling sir i see the center
from the knicks not patrick ewing the
other guy
i see cool in the gang i see uh the the
guy who ended up tackling cunningham
that was number 55 on the on the
remember the giants had two linebackers
they not only had lawrence taylor but
they have the other [ __ ] i saw
him in there i'm like oh [ __ ] and the
whole night i'm watching them and as
nine o'clock comes and they take away
the food
they play like black music and they're
dancing and you can see some of them
their jaws are gone
yeah and the word on the street is that
lawrence taylor shows up there
so i said [ __ ] it that's my hero yeah
and at this time if i meet my hero i'm
gonna have a [ __ ] jeebo i don't give
a [ __ ] what point what part of my
sobriety yeah i'm going off the deep end
for lt totally i [ __ ] shoot up i come
back friday with an eight ball i go to
the [ __ ] bar i'm sitting there i have
not done it yet i'm drinking at that
time in those days i used to drink rusty
nails
i like how deep i was at the cocaine
world but i would open up with uh
disgusting disgusting southern comfort
in orange juice oh i was uh you know
what back in that time neck of the room
for me was always seven and sevens and
white russians what about white russians
why russians have to it's too much sugar
yeah the next morning you wake up and
it's a sledgehammer i'm saying just to
kick start the party oh no no three or
four of them i love those i love those
i can't drink them all night i couldn't
put a little irish cream yeah but i
couldn't do it
irish
no the creamy one yeah almond milk
you can do that with that stop i
wouldn't put it on my mouth
what type of [ __ ] soldier would i be
that's the cream you would use for it
though yeah just that yeah just a touch
of it so now
i get to i called my name was tasia
i call taser i'm coming down that's one
whose house burned down yeah and they
called her and i go i got a package
she's gonna bring a cab let's have a
great time i go there i don't do nothing
i don't even i tell her i have a package
but it's coming
i'm gonna go it's ten minutes away yeah
she's calling the bar give it the phone
to joey because she knew everybody at
this time
she was there for like two weeks and by
this time she was running the joints she
was coming down tyler was attacked she
come down see you sitting there pulling
his tab hey he don't give me a hug she
was the real deal
so now
it's about 9 30
and who do i see walking
lt yeah with football shorts but cut
really no elastic
a leather jacket down to his ankles
white socks sneakers
and like a football practice jersey like
the ones with the holes in them yeah
yeah yeah no exactly
sure
he walks in with a leather jacket and he
orders like a cocktail he's wearing
essentially practice
a gear like he's covered leather coat
and it's it's it's uh it's june
now by that time yeah great of course
now by that time when you asked your
brother ari sophia by this time
not only were the the giants
the jets
the knicks hanging out there
but the generals were hanging out there
too and i met a guy that i used to talk
to every time i was in it his name was
herschel walker he was the nicest guy in
the world everybody says that and one
night
five years ago me and aria the ufc
and i look up and there's herschel
walking i asked gary oh hurry watch what
happens when he sees me
and as soon as he saw me he was like oh
[ __ ]
we couldn't talk the way we had been you
know man
i mean i saw him in there did he do
blown no he was he's the nicest guy in
the world he was not getting his dick
sucked there was white broad you know in
those days you could take a white broad
in the kong you you'll some ink you suck
and nobody said nothing in those days
yeah oh my god nowadays it's rape it's
great
no it's [ __ ] crazy so now i see isn't
that cool when somebody like that that
you're such a fan of you know you meet
him you know him you get to know him and
when they come by and they're like hey
joey what's up you're like holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] herschel [ __ ] walker [ __ ]
[ __ ] years that we
because i some and then i saw him once
and we reconnected like oh this guy's
good with faces
the time i saw him he surprised me so
when i saw him with ari i go he's going
to remember me and sure enough he goes
hey oh my god no [ __ ] remember you
totally remember jeff
it's crazy but here it is this is the
fiend i was you ready jason
i just called you jason yeah
i'm sorry
i'm cool with it
i'll just call you tebow don't tell me
whatever you want the story was lawrence
taylor orders a drink
and goes i gotta pee and he goes to the
bathroom and guess who follows him like
a little [ __ ] i'm gonna throw a stab at
you yeah of course and i follow him in
there and i walk up to him and i go dawg
i got some [ __ ] that killed the mule
and he goes off on me
really the [ __ ] are you talking about
get that [ __ ] away from me you punk-ass
[ __ ] i'll [ __ ] your world
he wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up was he
[ __ ] up already no okay he was
straight as an arrow okay
his eyes were clear i looked right in
his eye sure his jaw wasn't going see if
i [ __ ] up if his jaw was going he said
he would have said give me a taste of
that because once your jaw's going your
mind's thinking i might run out of mind
yeah let me take half of his nobody will
know nothing there's no cameras in the
bathroom once you're in you're in once
you're in here and lee how you doing
over there
look at lee you look a little stoned lee
i'm doing yeah i'm i'm actually doing
pretty well he's going austin with me
[ __ ] you i'm going to austin that's
gonna be fun are you guys gonna do a
live pod from there no nothing like that
you're just he's just coming along he's
coming along he doesn't he never goes on
on the road i know he's a foodie um you
love austin you know i i know in the
morning i'll wake up and we already be
gone i found a place that i can't i know
i can't go because he'll have spies
there now that i'm going to mention it
but all they do
is
cheeseburgers made with donuts like
donut for buns
i mean how far from the hotel i don't
know i don't know i don't know i didn't
do that search yet all right
we'll see see this is the [ __ ] he wants
fair food you want to eat fair foods i'm
not going to see if you guys go to
elephants
you're going to go there i don't blame
you don't take the pictures and come
talk about it on the podcast no i've
never had a
i've never had a dinner burger but
that's what yelp shows you oh and
actually
for all your yelp hate
did you see the uh or the news last week
that now they're allowed to
take money to uh boost reviews
yelp is yeah they just that's a kiss a
day they
they say they don't they say they don't
but they just want the right to that
ruins their legitimacy
yeah even if it's not already ruined you
know man
if you go on a website yeah before you
do business with somebody
you're three steps behind anyway
um i could call five people right now
and go lead you know a photographer
no but let me call paula maybe she knows
somebody right and right away so if you
say to me
i never understood that i take your word
your family
i take your word
why would i yelp somebody why would i
you know i'm a fat [ __ ] i hear things
about restaurants
i try them out do you want me to yelp
them to the world and throw the people
under the bus no
out here nine other [ __ ] 10
restaurants i go to eat ass they're
overrated i i don't get it but there's
also that other thing too where it's
like who goes to see a movie and
uh writes a letter to the theater that's
like hey i just want to let you know
everything went good i had a good time
at the movie thanks the air conditioning
was a little off but other than that my
husband sweat once the plane hit the
river with sully my husband started
sweating what the [ __ ] he knew what was
gonna happen [ __ ] yeah but with
the people that do
contact the movie theater are the people
that like hey that was a dead rat in my
[ __ ] popcorn and you know
if you're pissed off you won't you'll
take action if everything's fine you
don't say [ __ ] so you read all these
reviews and it's just a bunch of people
saying horrible [ __ ] yeah
i would never walk into a restaurant
because of a yelp review
i'd rather t row come over to me never
double you ever go to that i've never
done it when you work zany's joey around
the corner there's a place then yeah you
know what that meatball hero remember
with the fries they opened up one i'm
going because you told me
they're from you know it's so weird for
me and i try to [ __ ] with lee and i'm
happy he's going there but i have to
take lee like he's going to chicago
have you ever been to china before no
i've never been to chicago
you know the weirdest thing when i went
there last time and i hate saying this
in front of chicago people the last time
i went there
the best meal i had was oatmeal and
coconut milk
really the restaurant had it on the menu
and it was fantastic fantastic we're at
wherever zany's put me up a hotel oh
three doors out of the condo right
behind the club
but you never stayed there no they put
me in a hotel and like you're at the
downtown zany's then this time i'm in
rosemont that's right that's why
specials and rosemont but that place has
like those high-end restaurants when i
board down in zanies lee would like that
yeah like next time i take the special
because that's all i want to take away
going on wednesday and just let him walk
around leo come back 10 pounds heavier
he already shipped bratwurst oh to
[ __ ] california the guy's gonna mail
from austin's great though austin's
boston is great too chicago's great food
though chicago is great and the problem
with chicago
and places like that for guys like you
the native is that you know the response
you know it's like if i go then go
listen on planes cranes and car crashes
yeah the chef goes to this place yeah
and you're like listen joey ever since
he went in there at 15.99 i got a place
yeah where it's a black guy that picks
his nose that's how good it still is
sure and there's 699 with sauerkraut and
the lord and you follow me you know the
place so you know more where not to go
like right you know exactly where did
you go there on a saturday at
six o'clock you know you go to like rush
street to go have cocktails on a
saturday night it'd be like no nobody
there goes there that's like oh let's go
walk around hollywood boulevard on
friday night at 9 you know that's all
tourists you know it's all people that
want to you know nobody hangs out at
hollywood boulevard that lives in
hollywood
you know we avoid that place we go to
little cracks in the wall you know the
little dives
keep those places in business you know
what i mean giant corporate [ __ ]
fake places i like
i loved the mom and pop
i'll take a dive bar over with a jukebox
and 12 seats and that's it
and the same bartender that seems like
they live there like you could go there
at six in the morning you can go there
two in the morning they're still there
you know i'll take that over the [ __ ]
saddle ranch and all these big ass
[ __ ] that was the transition and
partying that got me
it was that was the transition and
partying where i fell apart
when i was young i went to a couple of
those clubs
it was fun
but i knew it wasn't my world you know
the big dance clubs uh the the one where
you drank for free till six that was
cool the couple of times the three or
four times i went out again for the
rooftop it was you know
i went with 10 of my friends you get
lost for two minutes and you meet him
again you talk
but i knew it wasn't my world i had
grown up in a neighborhood bar my mom
had a neighborhood bar she fed the
neighborhood they came in you drank when
the food's done there was always a
container on the bar with a sandwiches
cut already a little ham and cheese
sandwiches with a thing with a fly in
there you could open it up with the
flavor it was just that's the feeling i
want yes i go to a barn and i gotta hear
music i don't to [ __ ] hear him deaf
you go to vegas somebody asks you to go
to get a drink the music's [ __ ] black
i can't even hear you i can't no i want
to go to a place i don't want to hear
[ __ ] you want to shoot pool but
conservatively go over there once you
start bringing people look like
sons of anarchy i don't want to be there
i just want to be there
you know what i'm saying i want a place
where
the drinks are cheap yeah i could curse
nobody gets insulted yeah it
give me a bar where you can still smoke
inside when i first moved to hollywood
there was a place
on
santa monica and
gardner there's a little uh a fast food
joint there on the corner
okay okay it's [ __ ] you'll get
gonorrhea from eating this listen to me
but i listen to me but across from there
across these on elizabeth.com i'm going
to see where it is that's the [ __ ]
page he likes uh astro burger oh [ __ ]
that's so good astro burger it's still
there that's where astro burger is still
there but 10 15 years ago only the man
himself doug stanhope found the place
that the breakfast was good plus you
could smoke cigarettes in there
it was like they fronted it it was like
a restaurant with one table up front
they didn't really want those people
there and then you had to know the owner
and you go into the back and it was
outdoor seating oh i know exactly what
you're talking about
like a wooden fence
only side up i know exactly
[ __ ] oatmeal not bad it was like a
mexican name yeah yeah yeah something
there was something weird they were nice
people but i never mingled when you
would go in the restaurant part it
didn't even look like it was open
there'd be like one mexican guys
[ __ ] and they're like i just even then
when you go in the back there's like 40
people they had a petition to keep it
open and they [ __ ] lost
so i know exactly what you're talking
about you know the daniel stewart used
to live right by that place
wow
astro [ __ ] burger a lot of times i
wanted that two in the morning to get a
anything like a mushroom burger or
something they're burgers and i was
living in my car yeah you try living in
your car when you park down at four in
the morning you gotta go to the bathroom
and you're on e and you gotta start the
car and go to a park and take a [ __ ]
that's when astro burger yolanda hate
that [ __ ] because they failed you at a
tough time
it failed you at a tough time
i went there i gave you my confidence
now here i am with my nissan central
yeah on [ __ ] vista
parked the other way and i got to take a
[ __ ] i already fought it three times i
got the sunroof open
i got the four windows open how long
have you known stanhope what year did
you guys meet
did you meet in l.a no i met him
1991. get out i'm lying to you 1992.
i started comedy in june of 91.
i won the contest december 18th of 91
and i talked
the management at the broker in out of
the [ __ ] magician he had a magician
who was a host he was really old he was
just [ __ ] terrible and people would
throw [ __ ] at him really and i pointed
it out to the manager so they gave him
movie night
and they gave me comedy and i thought
not to hurt his feelings like listen
we'll put
do
his name was like magic always so he was
like
yeah
it was [ __ ] hard
so i started hosting at the broker in on
tuesday nights right for the bex comedy
night 1992 i had like eight minutes of
material
and
minutes every tuesday a new house can
you imagine joey diaz with only eight
minutes to his name oh my god oh my god
so you do the same eight minutes every
week no because the same customers came
in every week i don't already figure
that
after six months of comedy that the same
[ __ ] came in because not only
did you get to watch comedy for fifteen
dollars you got a steak a baked potato
and a [ __ ] salad
that's a good deal okay so people would
come in at 7 30 eat and then the comedy
show would start about 8 15 8 20.
cocktails too they got some open balls
no no no no no no oh yeah yeah and it
was known for being a big pickup joint
on wednesday nights okay wednesday was
uh their
mingle night from fine they put shrimp
bowls on people would go in there with
their fingers and eat shrimp oh my god
oh yeah yeah shrimp when you went to the
broker in those days and sat down to eat
dinner you know they bring you bread at
restaurants they brought you a shrimp
bowl
and you sat there and they had a curtain
so you could give your wife a stabbing
in there or sucky sucky or do a little
stabbing oh yeah yeah you can tuck some
dick into your wife oh yeah yeah this is
some crazy [ __ ] but that's where is it
still there still i don't know if it's
still there you have to look it up one
night on a tuesday night i went there
there was a kid with long hair skinny
young and his name was doug stanhope and
he was featuring
and we started talking and in those days
it was a complete run yeah so it was
bolder on tuesday you had wednesday off
and then you had to go to a [ __ ] up
part of colorado like [ __ ] up craig
colorado which is where this is i have
no idea and but on the itinerary when i
did comedy there six years later on the
itinerary for that night it said this
room is active
do not
in uh uh what's that when somebody says
something to you and you say something
back oh like interact do not interact
get off the stage go to your hotel room
and let management call you no really
why because it's it's like
when i got [ __ ] out or is it when i
got there it was it was you on the stage
20 feet of a [ __ ] open room and then
there was a glass and they would watch
you from the other side of the [ __ ]
glass
really because there had been so many
[ __ ] problems at this place where
comedians and comedians would lash out
at them and craig is like the side at
that time i don't know the population
now at that time it was
a thursday night that paid triple a lot
of money like three thousand dollars a
week they thought they were getting
[ __ ] milton berle and they were
getting doing the uncle milty they got
all joey diaz with his eight minutes of
comedy coming inside
you had craig on thursday
you know like colorado springs on friday
and you had something on saturday but
that tuesday night that wednesday hurts
you bro yeah because if you're a feature
trip only gives you 50 bucks you got 85
for the night you pick up 50. yeah a
hotel in those days is 25. you got a
subway sandwich a six pack of beers
you're breaking and you break a [ __ ]
a lot of those tribbles were always
breaking even you always breaking these
cut your chopsticks yeah because there's
a by the way during the week you're
doing that because you want stage yeah
you want to learn the money that you get
will get you to and from and probably
something to eat and maybe maybe a place
to sleep and that's it you don't come
back with money but you come back better
at comedy and seasoned
it's funny how uh so a little bit i used
to look at the comics i had just gotten
divorced
i had a two-bedroom house i had a living
room i had a couch had a tv
and i would look at how cool the
features were
or the headliner
you know they were dynamite guys like i
got along with stuff like a wasteland
they go i'm gonna think about getting a
hotel for 60 bucks i go
keep the 60. i was just i was a starving
comic i know i wasn't starving yet i
still had credit card money i still had
the condo because i was living in it and
i would bring them over and basically
pick their minds
let them sleep i'd have weed if they
wanted to do a couple bumps i'd get a
couple bumps from them
and we'd wake up in the morning they'd
take a shower and then go to craig
colorado
and stan hope was one of those guys i
met first time he came as a feature
eight months later he came back as a
headline he had just done
uh
the big show at the time inside the
improv what was the name of the night at
the improv not at the improv he had just
done that now he was a headliner
and he was on his way i could tell when
i saw him eight months later like this
kid's on his way you saw the difference
between featured a headlining there was
something in him
and then i didn't see him
we lost contact i got heavily into
comedy but i kept missing him then you
him and herself walker all ran into each
other yeah
i kept missing him i kept missing doug
stanley doug stanhope just been here
three weeks ago he ripped up this room
at this time it's 96 97
90 no
94 at this time i'm feeling you know
i'm okay i've been doing comedy for
three years on paper but solid for 18
months like a warrior yeah i got
something to work with people are i'm
still not bringing down the house but i
get my moments
and it's only gonna get better i'm into
it i write you know i do my thing i'm
living in my car
and i'm in seattle i go to seattle
and i actually start featuring up there
like that's the first i featured my
first feature weekend was for laurie
kilmartin she's a writer i know exactly
where she is and uh she still gigs
around every now and then yeah yeah
she's at the store and [ __ ] right and i
stayed there like jordan did the contest
do i semi-finals and there's a bunch of
[ __ ]
that uh
uh when uh whatever then 96 came
and dawg the hottest name in kylie
was doug stanley
like you heard about this from [ __ ]
everywhere mm-hmm that he won the san
francisco
i met him right after that and bam that
was it that was it was his style the
same thing like was he doing the same
stuff laziness
crazinessly so here's the story guys i'm
in seattle i'm doing all right as a
feature act you know
i'm not paying my bills
i'm trying to sell weed i'm hooking up
as a bookmaker like i told you josh wolf
has an office i got a 1-800 number i'm
fronting sports information i'm taking
numbers i'm working it you know i'm
trying to come out i got an addiction
i got a girlfriend who's a stripper who
i like how she sucks dick i gotta come
up with 200 for a dinner once in a while
so boom i got a feature spot on a friday
no i'm lying to you this is in seattle
it is in seattle guess who's coming to
town june like fifth or sixth herschel
walker doug stanley
and i had already made plans on the six
to go camping with the girl i was dating
yeah we had already had a campsite in
the truck and the whole [ __ ] thing
and i never forgot i said you know what
i'm a civilian this friday night in
those days
either you worked sunday through
thursday but unless you were working you
had the weekend off that's just that's
the level you're at yeah and you only
got one week in the month where you
worked in those days
you were just striving for feature spots
and more every once in a while you would
call me and go joey i got a headlining
gig that featuring 50 bucks in the hotel
room where i drive to portland let's
[ __ ] do it you know that's how you
learn to get into the club sure
featuring is the way in the club
people ask me that all the time like you
know
do your thing and then find somebody's
headline and again and get them to
feature for you that's the way in that's
the way they want you to get in no
that's the way come with somebody that's
kind of vouching for you i'll watch you
work for the weekend and i'll decide if
i want to you know have you come out and
then they work with you in a way they do
they start bringing you as a
co-headliner to have you fill the
holidays
so
friday night doug stanhopes in town
like june 5th or 6th of 1996
and at that time i had worked a lot of
good acts in seattle you know like
headliners and i'm like okay
i'm a good [ __ ] company mitch was up
there at the time
uh
tom rhodes you go up there there was a
lot of comics that were on the up and up
and dog i'm gonna tell you how it is
that [ __ ] got on stage for a
late show on friday night
and 20 years later i'm gonna tell you i
had never seen anything like that really
he tore that room in half
but at that time he was really wild
that's what he was doing is bucking a
vagina's joke yeah that's what he was
doing his uh
you know just just just the raw [ __ ] in
the world you know with the bikini the
the bikini was somewhere in there she
was so fat
it was like flaw dental floss or
whatever he was just throwing [ __ ]
heat
and i got this on my left eye that night
and i doubted myself i was like a
meeting that's when you know yeah that
was many times like that sadly like that
saturday and sunday i was like
maybe i could start being an electrician
again because i could i'll never be able
to do what i just saw this weekend
and i processed it and i go that's the
goal
that's the guy that's the guy you you
got to emulate that's the guy that
that thing that's wrong is right see
what i'm saying that's great that thing
that's wrong it's what's right there
that's what's going to get them to the
top and that's the style you want to
have yeah that thing that's wrong that's
right you know what it's very easy for
me to look in the mirror and go you know
what i'm a handsome 25 year old let me
go up there talk about this this this
and this and take my [ __ ] chances not
have any chops
and then there's the guy that uh
knows where he's coming from
you know he
i don't even know what happened i'm so
[ __ ] all right look at this [ __ ]
jamaica then you you're high you're
looking at me hypnotizing me trying to
make me [ __ ] higher yeah you look
this i know i said it last time i was
here and the time before that i believe
i said it but this time i really mean it
this is the highest i've ever seen you
look well it's only twelve hundred
milligrams that's it
did you take an extra two
nah i did i didn't yes i did one i took
it before you you looked at me like a
milk so i didn't know
let's get him to eat some more yeah he
needs two more he's saying
he's got to get earlier you need two
more bro
you look good thanks buddy i feel good
really good your eyes look really
[ __ ] good oh really i'm gonna almost
start to think you're hitting them
a little like
right around eight months right now you
know went out had uh
uh had a meltdown one weekend
uh just anger
anger
you know
and then actually i talked to you right
at right right then
walter right after that and you know
it's just
and then you know one thing that you got
to do is like and you and i say that all
the time it's like man
this ain't a perfect thing
you know and it's like it's shit's gonna
get to you man and when it does you just
gotta get right back up right and that's
the difference between me and like all
anytime ever when i've been sober it's
like when you when i would [ __ ] up i'd
be like nah man see i already [ __ ] up
might as well just be out for a [ __ ]
till it's really bad again
you know what i mean
it's like you gotta just like dude okay
cool man it's another day it's another
day
there's a moment every day where i look
around my surroundings i look at lee i
look at you
i look at my wife
delicate it's delicate i look around and
i look at the people in my life now and
i look to the people that i had in my
life then
and for some reason every day just to
keep me sane and i look at all these
things
for a split centimeter
because that's where we get the
addiction from
i think of the darkness for like a split
second when you think of uh
running into a building and what your
life used to be like and it's like a
[ __ ] movie
it really is that you don't even
remember being in it plays in my head
like a movie i went to hollywood they
took a side street
and i got goosebumps that was the street
i used to make the right
and but there's a little jewish center
for kids you just randomly did it not
even
in those days there was no kids being
shot yet so there was no security guard
so i would park right in the juice
center just away with the teachers and
they would wave back at me but once
somebody got shot
somebody got shot around here and
wilshire boulevard somebody only got a
they had security guards so i couldn't
park that no more i used to park you'll
get blow
and you think of those creepy nights
me and my wife always have a
conversation where i made it take me at
three in the morning to get blow i lied
to her we gotta go over and get a cd for
a movie
i haven't auditioned tomorrow i have to
watch this film horrendous
and i can tell it doesn't take a genius
to know that she knew why she was there
at three in the morning parked outside
the building eventually
you might get away with it a couple
times but eventually
you're gonna be like come on man
we both know what's going on here at
least be honest you know
i thought to myself the times i thought
i could never even imagine that my life
would be clean
never mind be married and have a child
there was never it all starts with one
day it all starts with one moment
ever
you know for people who think it's i i
for two [ __ ] years
the last [ __ ] you know what i would
do let me tell you the deepest [ __ ]
because what the [ __ ] why do a podcast
so we can't get deep totally you know i
would be one of those guys that i would
snort
half the package
and lose it that was where i was i could
take a gram of the vegetables like you
can't find it was it no no no no losing
in my mind like sure i'm the type of guy
that the way i am with weed is the way
i've always been listen you see how you
said i was myself in town
in town so when you meet that mexican
you call me and you would call me a
professional go joey listen you go there
and come i got a guy you got to see this
[ __ ] clean 1980s
eyeballs the whole [ __ ] thing
and at those days i was snorting half
the package i'd go upstairs and whack
off
and then i'd go out make believe i was
writing
and i'd do uh
a couple more little [ __ ] bumps you
know and then the last package i would
take inside and lock the door in the
bathroom
and i would actually
do them in front of the mirror to prove
to the mirror this is the last time i
was doing coke right and i'd have a
40-minute conversation with the mirror
i'm going to [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] your
mother you [ __ ] up my life you son of
a [ __ ]
and i faked the tears
you [ __ ] my life up but and i ripped
the coke and i'd throw in the [ __ ]
toilet and like that's it i'll never do
coke again that's a lot now would you
actually throw coke away or just that no
i wouldn't like the empty pack of course
you're [ __ ] confused yep no i'm
[ __ ] confused i had a wall in boulder
i had the rocky apartment downstairs and
i had this shitty bathroom that you
actually
slid a door open
and it was a metal shower
it was 400 a month i didn't give a [ __ ]
you know and they had a sink and a nice
bathroom the landlord was a cool
[ __ ]
but he had put a piece of sheetrock up
and never finished it and there was a
little slip back there
so the last of my coke i had windows in
the apartment so i would never do coke
out there so i would always take him to
the bathroom and do the last little bit
and lick it and throw in that wall oh my
god one time after like nine months
in my mind i was convinced i threw one
in there with a [ __ ] package
i ripped the wall open that's addiction
and i gotta be honest there were so many
little packages i was embarrassed i was
like oh my god
i didn't want but i guess what i did i
opened each one of them
and licked each one licked them looked
in there snorted it and then oh my god
incredible it's incredible so i think i
had [ __ ] for two minutes i remember one
time looking in the mirror uh
my buddy had a gun
and they were coming in uh too and it
was an un
wasn't his gun
and but the landlord's coming to like do
like all these inspecting things so he's
like hey man let me put you know it's in
the case all that kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] store this at your place until
the landlord's done doing this whole
inspection i don't want to see this
[ __ ] gun so i had it under the bed it
wasn't loaded it wasn't loaded i don't
even think i had bullets for it but i
remember being [ __ ] hammered i was
coked up i was drinking by myself doing
coke by myself
um the party's long over long over
even though it lasted another five four
or five years but i remember looking in
the mirror and putting that gun in my
mouth
and just looking at myself and being
like
that's how it got this it'll go down
like that i can make and because i
wanted to see what it looked like
like with me with a gun in my mouth
and then i and i started crying be very
honest then i started crying because i
was like i wasn't crying because i was
like at that point in my life but i was
crying because i was like
who's making these [ __ ] decisions
i'm not the kind of dude that just like
puts a gun in my mouth and is like
let me see what it looks like you know
if i'm going to kill myself because i
was so depressed and so
who's making those [ __ ] decisions
who's what part of my brain goes
yeah that gun's under your bed man you
could put that in your [ __ ] mouth so
you just see what it looks like you
don't even have bullets don't even have
bullets
who
what mechanism in my brain is in charge
of that [ __ ] and it's always been my
addiction man it's always been
it's always it's always you know and as
long as that's i was talking to this kid
uh i met this kid at a uh at a meeting
today and he was a fan of comedy you
know and he's a fan of podcasts so he's
like man i saw you this meeting
was really
a surreal moment for me because i
actually hear you talk on different
podcasts and
and all that sort of [ __ ]
and he's like you know i'm an aspiring
young comedian too and blah blah blah
and um
but i don't know if i'm
an alcoholic or not i don't know if i'm
an addict or not
and you know i'm just kind of trying to
figure that out i go but he's like well
why did you
as far as comedy what was one of the
reasons that you quit i mean because i
really quick because i was going to die
or just have a horrible life
and i was like because i can't compete
at the level of comedians i hang out
with
with booze and drugs in my life
you know you think
you know you
rogan
you know all these different ari all
these different when i was doing open
mics yeah man i could drink and do blow
and [ __ ] bang with them
you know when you're featuring yeah you
can but when you start getting to a
level where everybody's got a goddamn
you know fourth degree black belt in
comedy
if i'm [ __ ] slipping up and getting i
can't compete
you know i'm just a dude that drives
home and it's like man i better go back
to plumbing i better rethink this game
because you know
it's like it's all about giving yourself
a [ __ ] chance for me for me
no i listen i feel the same [ __ ] way
i remember going you know what i've done
movies i've done tv sure i can't get
[ __ ] arrested this has to end i
remember being on a plane and rogan
throwing one of his [ __ ]
remarks out and going you know man
when one thing is broken in your life it
affects everything
and that's saying stay with me for about
a year it ate at me every time i did a
line of coke it really did
the worst the worst is knowing better
having like knowledge in your head and
then [ __ ] booze in your gut and
you're like why i think about it hi some
nights when i'm bored i'm like can you
imagine me right now going to
a bar in hollywood and getting the gram
and
locking myself in the hotel room and
doing a couple bumps how much you would
hate yourself no no no i couldn't even
imagine i couldn't even imagine i don't
even want it in my [ __ ] hand
i can't even have i'm to the level in my
life that i was around
drunk people since i was [ __ ] full my
mom had a ball
i'm done
i'm done i just want to smoke a number
and relax and go back to my room and
maybe there's some [ __ ] milky way or
something or [ __ ] bottled water and
you just sit and
you watch an episode or you go to bed
that's the excitement i want it's so
[ __ ] weird how you everything changes
you know and you guys were talking
earlier but like i bought like the bars
you liked
a few weeks ago my girlfriend was away
in europe i was bored one night i tried
i tried to go
to two bars
one bar i went to
was up the street from where i used to
live and irish brown they were singing
karaoke so that was that was out i'm out
i don't want that and then there was a
sports bar
down the street from my house
so i went there and at like 11 p.m
on either friday or saturday there was
literally three people in the bar
so i had i literally i
i had a diet coke and i left but those
are the bars of the parties going on you
just gotta turn that [ __ ] loose
you sit there you have a couple those
are the nights where i had the best time
going maybe having three quarters of a
gram in my pocket
going into a bar like that you order a
beer they ask you for 250 you're like
two friends yep oh [ __ ]
what do you want let me see seven beers
the ladder i know yeah yeah
yeah yeah you're the only person coming
out i don't know how old are you
oh my god those are the spots yeah they
got the sinatra on the jukebox the
bartender's got cheese and crackers in
the back shuffleboard they got yeah this
this and you don't want this i know
there's bars like that across the
country like
like i said you know what if
my extent the ball like you know what i
miss having a good lunch at a bar
like just a bar that's dirty
that you know there's rats in there but
the lunch is sensational yeah and they
have the tv on they have sports center
on you catch up for an hour they have a
12 o'clock service fries and a blt kind
of thing something like that but a
little bit more healthier like nothing
fried like maybe a salad or like a nice
meal
you know a salad with vinegar oil maybe
uh
like uh who the [ __ ] knows without my
[ __ ] bobby flay i don't [ __ ] know
what the [ __ ]
you described an incredible me like
everything you're gonna eat to him in uh
austin
oh yeah that's gonna be awesome please
lee's got his own menu he's got his
whole [ __ ] name let me give some
shout outs sure buddy
we got my man big billy 91
my parish mickey
joey zaza tweets
loco nuka
danielito traversio
randy perez
crystal johnson thank you for going for
black sabbath and giving me the review
and morgan mma there you go
you got any [ __ ] tour dates uh i
would when does this go up i mean i know
it's live on youtube right now okay so
this is
this weekend friday i'm at the ice house
uh sunday i'm at the melrose improv
and end of september i am in la jolla at
the comedy store down in san diego with
theo vaughn all weekend
and then november 4th i'm at the tiger
room in fort wayne indiana recording my
new album return to the red state
and that's two taping so if you want to
go to that hit me up
and uh otherwise look for that probably
the first week of christmas
and as always punch punch on sports.com
you can listen to me r and sam fight
every tuesday from noon to two you're
really putting it together the pieces in
your life man brother dude every little
day that you don't [ __ ] go backwards
you at least are going forwards but the
most astonishing thing of what the
situation happened
is that i was notified
by three or four people on twitter yeah
to check on you
that you were saying some things that
you were saying some things and i
remember calling you and you called me
back and then you said what had happened
and i'll never forget that that i found
out
from people who really cared about you
on twitter that knew i cared about you
yeah and i was like till this day i
always apologize to twitter for the [ __ ]
i sent five years ago in the joe rogan
podcast who the [ __ ] what kind of people
you want to be friends with on twitter
we have a great [ __ ] community it's
amazing for them to reach and now they
got brody on watch
those [ __ ] on twitter got brody
on speed watch jack dude you know what
was cool about that exact same thing all
these twitter fans are also great like
mickey gall who just fought cm punk
been a fan of punch drunk been listening
starts calling in gets a ufc contract
now he you know he calls pretty
regularly
but all of our fans on our show have got
to know this guy and then see him get
his first you know this is this guy's
dream come true he's a 24 year old guy
fighter
you see his dream the twitter
like every fan of pawn trunk went to
some bar or ordered the fights not
because they wanted to see me oh sick in
the in overeem heavyweight they're like
i gotta see [ __ ] mickey gall
you know cause they've been listening to
him dude the support he got just from
our fans on our show was
it was moving to me
you know them having my back you know
when i'm like [ __ ]
you know it's it's
very connected dude we're all very
connected i do a periscope and i always
say man we're a family where else can
family sit down for 10 minutes and smoke
dope with your [ __ ] uncle joey listen
to a side of an album yeah this couldn't
happen this couldn't [ __ ] happen so
i love it and i love what's going on
with you
i think about how lucky i am i swear to
god teams every day that i got that
curse off my back
me too i have to it all started with
martin the fact i've always thought
about that martin the fact put a curse
on me for stealing his coke
he went to the cuban gods and he says if
he wants to smell coke let him snort
coke let's get them all the coke he can
mm-hmm and that's what happened they
threw a [ __ ] voodoo curse on me and
i don't know how it got cleansed off me
but give the [ __ ] dude you're here now
man christ i think about
just how lucky
the love of christ
yeah and it's like you know
there's also a huge part of me that's
like i've been there done that like what
more can i do
playboy mansion a bunch of time i mean
there's nothing you can
what party am i going to go to where i'm
like oh this now it's worth it i did it
all i really had a 20-year run where i
did some amazing incredible damage some
of it was fun so it was quite fun
but it's like
you know i'm trying to come up you know
what i mean i'm trying to
live up to my potential i'm trying to be
the kind of dude that helps other people
who need to get out of the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that i was in you know from there it's
whatever from there it's whatever but
being that dude that's stuck in that
[ __ ] hole that can't help himself
isn't going to cut it anymore for the
second half of my life first half yeah
that's what happened for the most part
second half not so much you know and to
be able to
to have that wherewithal to be like you
know if anybody's struggling hit me up
you know
so many people from the last time i was
on your show i've talked to on facebook
twitter you know back and forth of like
hey man you know what what did you do
you know i'm just as [ __ ] i sound like
i'm just as [ __ ] as you were
you know
a lot of these people are still sober a
lot of them are at least
cognizant of the fact that this is
this ain't something to [ __ ] with man
i've lost a lot of friends
to drugs and alcohol related
you know overdosing suicide car accident
hit by drunk driver drunk driving
themselves
you know i've tried to talk to lee about
this for the last couple weeks and
i did something i never [ __ ] do man i
finally cut somebody off
and told i was once told by a dear
friend of mine
it was another way of telling me to go
[ __ ] myself he looked me straight in the
face and he goes the next time i see you
you better be pulled up in front of my
house with a white cadillac
don't call until then and it killed me
for a few minutes but then i thought
what he was saying to me and he made a
lot of sense
and i finally had to say that to
somebody and it felt great like don't
call me until you get away [ __ ] you
drive it with a white cat like mm-hmm
because it just got too much this is not
gonna end good we you and i
we we see the [ __ ]
and i've been her friend for you know 15
20 years and what killed me was she had
it
the people 99 of the time they do yeah
she had it like if you can just get out
of your own way she was doing comedy she
was hanging out drinking sodas
no drama because you could tell when
she's drinking she doesn't have to tell
you you don't have to smell it the
behavior
the behavior changes and the funny thing
is you think you can lie
oh you see a sweaty joey diaz come up
with the jaw going in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know no well i would talk
at a different level i would but i would
never
do a line and go on stage the problem
with me was that i was telling somebody
that
i would do so much the night before
like i was sweating all the [ __ ] time
lee you're sweating out
yesterday wait a minute oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you were gonna tell me i was sweating
yesterday i don't know it wasn't no no
i'm saying that's just when you people
would see you think you were jacked up
no you're sweating now yesterday [ __ ]
i'm not even i'm not even jacked up for
like another couple hours well when i
was 370 and i would go on stage right i
wouldn't have material i thought i was
cuter than everybody else
you know rogan was feeding me like just
go up there and say this you [ __ ]
knock them dead yeah and i would go up
there like a wild man
and i would start bombing at the six
minute point and i would have a 20
minute set
lee i could tell you as a man it would
pour out of me and he's my witness
it would even in the in the original
room i would give them if i were to pour
this on my oh my god cocaine had my body
that whacked
i couldn't walk from here to the car
if i stayed on the heat a little bit and
i started sweatingly i'd lose a [ __ ]
gallon of water in no time
[ __ ] there's different times in like in
the in in the comedy community that we
you know i'm gonna say grew up because
we grew up in different areas of the
country but at the comedy store in the
hollywood scene
it's
a lot of times it's somebody's turn in
the barrel they say you know what i mean
it's like uh you know there was times
where everybody was so worried about you
everyone's like man i don't know man
joey
he's looking big he's always on a lot of
coke man i don't know if his heart can
take that kind of lifestyle then do you
remember when ari had his run when he
was going through depression and always
very depressed all the time and talking
about suicide a little too much too
seriously you know that was his kind of
turn in the barrel it's like when you go
through it it's like
you know like you were saying with your
friends like you you know
she had it
but then you just go right you know you
get right back into brown and eventually
everyone's got to be like all right
we're all going to do what we can to try
to help this person but eventually you
got to meet halfway i gotta meet you
halfway every [ __ ] person can't tell
me hey you gotta quit doing this hey
joey you gotta start taking care of
yourself hey you gotta you know you
gotta take it buddy i know [ __ ]
you think i don't know that
you know you have to be willing to go
like all right yeah yeah yeah you're
right i'm sick of this [ __ ]
you know
i can't believe how much of a mess i
really was
yeah
and every day that i look back i see how
much of a mess
i mean not socially and
physically sure just emotionally yeah i
was going through something
and looking back it was the whole thing
that went on and boulder how angry i was
they were screwing me over it was
affecting me and
at night i'd go home and i couldn't deal
with it you know at night i didn't want
to be me you know i can really relate to
that 100 at night you don't want to be
you you just the last thing you want to
do is go home in those days leave your
my friend right you were out till five
every night paul was waiting for me by
the way we're hanging out
let's talk about the podcast we have we
already talked about this eight times
i don't wanna play [ __ ] spanish music
i don't wanna play spanish music no it's
amazing i'd have him out wasting his
[ __ ] time every night so tebow like
did you have any when joey called you
did you have any urge to lie to him and
said no i didn't i didn't drink
uh
sure yeah i think you always will
i think you always will but i mean you
know
you know there'd be people
who you know you might just for the sake
of an argument or it's not their
business whatever but it's like you know
i knew what he was calling and it's like
i'm not gonna if i'm not taking
advantage of having those kind of
relationships in my life like to be
fortunate enough to have somebody like
joey that's like hey listen i heard not
doing so good give me a call i want to
talk to you it
i lose i lose
what the universe gave me that
connection for if i don't take advantage
of it be honest you know if i don't call
them back and be like hey man here's
what's up thanks for calling blah blah
blah you know
right yeah because like i can i can see
where you're like my first reaction
would be to lie of course especially
with something like your [ __ ] like i
would like if i'm ashamed about it yeah
yeah shame is a big [ __ ] for
that
you know like shame shame will keep you
out anger will keep you out resentments
will keep me out any little [ __ ]
angle
you know it's always looking for
something
excuse me
oh my god that's those stars got me deep
and [ __ ] and they take me out don't you
gotta take two more stars me
no
they take me in and out like they like
that like for three minutes how many
milligrams is one star 200
so if you have so if you the more you
just keep eating those the more [ __ ]
you are i've had four i've had 1400
after appointing to law diminishing
returns i thought well of course liam
and i have discussed we're throwing good
pot at bad pods we gotta eat we can eat
three more and the three more we'd be
[ __ ] gone but you guys really have a
red eye tonight yeah tonight yeah what
time do you well how many did you uh eat
last night four
five there were a couple purples and a
few reds
let's estimate maybe 700. okay we were
pretty [ __ ] live for about an hour
and a half yeah
like we got high for an hour and a half
that would kill a meal are you going to
eat a bunch before the flight oh we're
eating already it's all over no i mean i
mean on your way there yeah [ __ ] yeah we
always eat some cause this guy they're
going to be like oh sir you don't look
chinese in your eyes yeah they're gonna
be [ __ ] up lee and [ __ ] and then we're
gonna keep him on the kalino's with time
and he knows this is his magical mystery
dog
there really is lee really doesn't
understand this that
this is it you know i mean uh
i don't do drugs i don't drink it's not
like there's gonna be women involved but
you know what man people in texas are
[ __ ] crazy
yeah you know what they make edibles too
and they're [ __ ] rednecks they throw
everything in there peanuts
right [ __ ] the tofu they don't give
them
more lizard meat barbecue sauce you know
and next thing you know you're eating a
cookie with 280 milligrams you eat four
of them because they're [ __ ]
delicious they put custard in there and
corn milk those are the ones that are
the always the most date when you can't
even taste it where you're just like oh
that can't be that that can't be that
strong because i can't taste it so then
you have a [ __ ] another one and then
it's like a [ __ ] boom
you smoke a joint you smoke a [ __ ]
cup of bong rips whatever
you know
pretty much like how much you hit it you
know like oh okay whatever some of these
edibles is a real [ __ ] you pick them
it's a mystery of how hard that's going
to hit you that's the beauty yeah that's
the [ __ ]
listen when you eat a valium you expect
something
when you do a hit of heroin you expect
something yeah [ __ ] thc
you really don't know what to and that
was
that was my first allure
as a kid to drugs at first
after my mother died the addiction
became the cocaine for the pain
but in the beginning i was into doing uh
like hits acid and i would make myself
and my friends
go into new york city
an adventure yeah and they would look at
me and go dawg i can't handle that yes
you would the same way i'd literally
right let's go
come on
i got you back let's yeah we go just do
acid and walk around the city stop go
over like kids
being 15 and a half 16 because my mom
was still alive
go over there once you get over there
you can get a bottle of vodka anywhere
in those days in 80 79 78 somebody was
in front of a liquor store yo mister can
you go in and get me a bunch that was
always a game give me a dollar fifty and
give me a dollar fifty extra for myself
if you were walking into a liquor store
right now and there's some 15 year olds
outside and asked you to do that would
you buy it for them not anymore yeah
i'll throw you in jail for 20 years sure
it's not worth it you know
i mean if i knew them and i knew the
parents and there was
i'm the type of guy that
there's a little bend in my game if it's
a necessary reason and you present it to
me
in a gentlemanly fashion okay you know
it's uh i when i called you and you
called me back i really respected you
more than i ever respected you because
one of the things i hate the most
tebow i heard you bombed in columbus no
i didn't i did great lee called me knows
he did great
you know i don't know what the [ __ ] you
doing come on sir i'm not that type of
comic sure if somebody asked me a
question about tebow's
youth or whatever i can't answer it but
one thing that bothers me is when one
junkie
lies to another mm-hmm
because you know if i walked in here
right now and i had done a bump at four
in the afternoon
you wouldn't accuse me but a guy like
you would go hmm
he's not acting like him
he was essentially yeah you follow me
he'll take that home well because it's
like you
you can fool
the normal people yes
you could i could fool my sister you
could fool different people
but when you know it and you see it
you're like
you know why are you wearing sunglasses
at night you know why you you know what
i mean your eyes are jet black and you
can't [ __ ] sit still it's like come
on man you know don't
yeah
it's crazy lee and then you'll see that
and then
nothing will happen it sits in your mind
and then one day you'll bump into red
band or you hear about joe diaz what
dog the other he didn't come home for
three days his wife called me the baby
he's been [ __ ] somebody's house doing
blow again oh no
and you know you know what it makes
sense now that day i saw him at the
podcast that's it he was acting all
[ __ ] fidgety and [ __ ]
yeah that's it you know you'll see [ __ ]
like and you're just like of course or
you can just look back with a lot of
people like that too and go like oh yeah
now it all makes sense because he didn't
show up for this and then he blew that
gig off and then he [ __ ] you know
wasn't showing up but now it all makes
sense
because a lot of times like that's the
thing if my
if i'm pub if
it's almost like how you were saying
about betting earlier if this guy says
150 granny 175 grand it's like that kind
of thing
if if my drinking is enough that i'm
you're seeing me in public drunk
i didn't just start drinking today yeah
you know what i mean
i got too much to risk to be showing
around so i'm gonna have a couple sneaky
[ __ ] ah let me just get a six-pack
watching monday night football game
drink it by myself no one will [ __ ]
know that [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] know
you know it's a month later before i got
the balls to start showing up hammered
in places
respect you a lot and i respect what
you're doing i love you very much sir
you're a very uh
positive influence in my life and
growing you know what i was in a dark
place uh a lot of people helped me man
and a lot of people help me by not
saying something sure you follow me
absolutely a lot of times a lot of
people help you by not saying something
it's their body language and the things
they do say that you put two and two
together so so i i would be someone who
would be like
i would be really like
upset like you're out upset with myself
to know whether to say something or not
to say something how do you know whether
to say something
i mean i think every instance is
different with different people
i had the weirdest people say things to
me i would say that that's true for me
too i had people outside
that i thought would say something to me
say things to me one of them was at the
end was rogan
but i had a
claude stewart claude stewart once
checked dude i've known him for a long
that's crazy what did claude stewart say
just pulled me aside and said you don't
look good hmm and i've been way wrong
you just had a kid
well his wife did and he goes um
i could get you into a rehab in san
diego on one call they'll take care of
this for you
and i remember like a week later i had
like a bad coke bench
and actually called him and said get the
car ready yeah but i stayed off it for a
day i i got a check from residual and i
went and got another gram and blew them
all sure totally and he was offering to
pay for it at the time wow
i just want you to get home you don't
looking too good
hey man
i'm very [ __ ] fortunate i had good
people around me
they made me believe and somehow i got
out of that [ __ ] mess man i mean look
at you now man look at you now [ __ ]
scary
if i would have told you 10 years ago
here's your life no you would have been
like get the [ __ ] out of here momo get
out of here mama baby i'm going to be
doing blow in the hotel room in houston
texas
after i just that's what i told you 10
years ago
here's your life you wouldn't believe it
and then 10 years ago i thought i told
you
that on this date you're dead and you
died of an overdose you've been like
that's right cox i got guns blazing
that's how i'm going i thought i would
die from an overdose i absolutely i was
prepared
are you okay so you're okay with it you
really you made peace with it
at that time i just i know the deal the
more spaghetti you go and throw against
the wall
the
the mort's going to stick and you don't
know what the lord's conquering the call
and it always happens in a weird place
you end up going to some town you know
you're married at home with a wife you
go to a town you pick up some [ __ ]
check out the comedy club she's doing
blow you go back to the room you get a
[ __ ] heart attack you gotta explain
to people what that's how that goes down
that's how it always goes down the
clinker for me the truth
the one that opened my eyes was in 99 a
comic hung himself
at one of the clubs and i knew him
not well
he worked the broker
and that wednesday he picked up a gig in
fort collins so he goes do you want to
drive
and that was the first time i had ever
seen a mirror
like on the way up there all he talked
about was gambling
and
drugs that's the truth but here's the
beauty of it this guy was i was whatever
it was 94 when i met him
i was 31 years old
95 when i met him
and
he killed himself
99 maybe four years later so
whatever i was 32 and i remember he hung
himself on new year's eve in a hotel
room in houston
off the balcony or something like
but the shame about this guy was that he
was out here
for like three years and he was touted
to be heavy duty like they were like
this is the dude yeah but his little
problem got discovered
he went on one of those road trips and
just stayed in oklahoma for a month and
that was the end of that nobody wanted
to see him again
so for the last 10 years he had just
been a road dog yeah but he was still
like people would look at you look at
him on stage and go damn hopefully
someday and now he had taken his clean
comedy routine tv act
and tailor it to [ __ ] bars in the
midwest
you couldn't follow him nobody followed
nobody right he was killing it you know
the day i had him that day in fort
collins
he had to run to the phone eight times
to gamble
he asked me to get him an eight ball and
then before the night was over he called
me back and he was getting me another
one i just did you do it already no no
but i just want to be prepared
oh that was nothing
now yeah when they want to be prepared i
know the deal because i used to want to
be prepared yeah that's when you're in
the [ __ ] heart of it lee syed
yes we're very fortunate this week
the church of what's happening now is
when i introduced a new uh
a new product that's uh
sponsoring us i
love this [ __ ] idea
you know i don't know if you guys know
anything about me or whatever when i was
doing that coke and [ __ ] i became a
nomad and i would to come down from coke
i would go in the shower
in a hotel or in my apartment and i
would just lay in the [ __ ] tub and i
would put the hot shower on
and i would whack off to come down off
the coke like two or three times and
then
after a while you gotta take a pee do
you think i'd actually get up and go to
the tub
or the [ __ ] no i just pee on my legs
like a chicken
and then after another hour the cocaine
would start to wear into my system and
guess what would have to happen i got to
take a little poop
so i would actually get up in the shower
and poop
and
i would turn around and bend over like a
like a [ __ ] porno star with the
muffler out and as the poop was coming
out and have the water hitting it
because that's the type of sandwich and
then you would just [ __ ] in the shower
and i'd [ __ ] in the shower and then i
turn around with my hand and i pick up
the lid to the toilet and i flick it in
like michael jordan like an underhoop
and i'd wash my hands in the shower what
percentage did not make it into like 100
but once my wife caught me it was over
she threatened to throw me the [ __ ] out
of the house you can't throw [ __ ] from
room to room no kidding let me tell you
why i did that
let me tell you why i did that because i
grew up with a bidet
really in your house in new jersey and i
remember i remember moving in the first
day
and running into my mother's room and
looking around the room and here's this
toilet and here's the shower with a tub
and here's this beautiful sink
but wait a second in between the toilet
and the sink there's another toilet and
i'm like what the hell is this
it looks like a toilet but it didn't
have a hole it had a thing in the middle
so what did i do i stuck my head over
the thing and i'm like that's where
water comes out so all of a sudden i
turn the water on like this very gently
and all of a sudden i turn the hot water
on very gently but the hot water slips
and the water shoots at you know it's
all over your face and all over the
[ __ ] ceiling and like brahma what the
[ __ ] is this and she told me it's a
bidet but
so i never knew what the hell she was
talking about i always thought it was
used it was a woman product
sure i saw my stepdad sitting there and
i'm like oh [ __ ] when they leave tonight
i'm like oh that my mom was going don't
go in the room when we leave as soon as
they go in the room
i'd be holding a little poop in there
and i'd poop and i'd sit in that thing
like a doctor at the age of eight and
nine i'd just be [ __ ] sitting there
letting my muffler get washed with hot
water
i wash my muffler in that hot water like
i would take regular poops in my
bathroom
but that one good poop of the day i
would always jump in there because i
wanted the muffler to be clean and i'd
have the right formula of hot and cold
water in those days you just took a bar
of soap and you put the indentation
where your fingers went so you never
touched the other side and after i
cleaned all the peanuts out in the fecal
matter well i would put the [ __ ] bar
of soap in there like money molly and i
let that hot water kill everything the
germs and everything and that was the
end of that but when my mother died that
all ended
so for 30 years i lived with a savage
like a savage who the [ __ ] hasn't been
dead who's got that type of class
that's james bond type of [ __ ] yeah but
all of a sudden a buddy of mine said to
me listen man take a look at this
[ __ ] thing this
is tremendous and i love the name hello
hellotushy.com
church okay let me tell you people some
that aren't aware of it you're sitting
there confused but days are back let me
tell you what a bidet is a bidet is
something that sprays your butt clean
with fresh water okay i grew up with a
bidet in my house and i gotta tell you
as a fan i'm they're tremendous now
thanks to tushy sleek bidets that clip
on your existing
toilet and they spray your muffler
completely clean if you don't know what
muffler is it's butt completely clean
with fresh water to get your muffler
clean so you're not sitting on bacteria
causing hemorrhoids yeast infection and
rotten ass which will really kill you
nothing else kills you like rotten ass
because it goes through your jeans next
thing you know people are smelling it
and they're like who farted it's just
you you know anyway you don't need to
know about all that stuff and
one other thing but days are also better
for the environment because there's no
paper more trees my friend and
each little muffler wash uses one pint
of water that's how event
environmentally
safe they are and number the best tushy
stands behind their product for 30 days
money back guarantee what they want to
do is this go to the webpage right now
hellotushy.com capital h e l o capital t
u s s y
s h y dot com
go right now take a look at what they
got you're gonna be impressed they got
two types of bidets they're gonna rock
your world you thought your muffin was
gonna stay dirty that ends today go to
hellotushy.com right now go to slash
church go to the box and press in church
and get 10 off your order okay that's
how i'm gonna do it just for you going
to the webpage right now today it's a
tremendous christmas present if
somebody's birthday let's pretend you
went on a date
you know you took it to a restaurant you
went down there and you smelt something
listen
who doesn't need a bidet more than that
girl you understand me true and how you
give it to us listen
she'll look at you all weird you go no
no no no no no no no listen
this is because i'm going to go down
there like a savage i'm going to take
you running around the world [ __ ]
tour and they understand what you're
saying the day they'll love it anyway
go to hellotushy.com right now slash
church and preston church for ten
percent off that's how i'm doing it
right now today for you that's the type
of savage i am all right
again that's capital h e l o
capital t u
s h y dot com
slash church go to the webpage look at
all the fine options they have to offer
you're right i love this product and so
the [ __ ] will you
and next is my people of people thank
god i'm going to austin because one of
the things i'm doing
i'm going to honor dawg i'm going to get
a box of those mixed greens i'm going to
get as much [ __ ] hemp protein as i
can i'm going
down there you know why because on it
works the alpha brand you got 100 money
back guarantee okay who does who gives
you that type of [ __ ] if the product
don't work you don't like it it ain't
working for you you get you caught we
don't even want the product back bam
we'll give you your [ __ ] guitars back
but it all starts by you going to
honor.com and look at the fine line of
supplements also they have weights
kettlebells i can't get you hooked up on
those but supplements i'll get you 10
off right now go to the box and press in
charge boom
c-h-u-r-c-h and i'm getting you 10 off
again do me a favor go to
hellotushy.com right now i'll tell you
why the holidays are coming and i'm
going to get you out of there nice and
cheap cheap and who doesn't need a bidet
who doesn't have a dirty [ __ ]
everybody nobody loses nobody's going to
go what a surprise i didn't need one and
then i'm excited because ever since you
get a girlfriend you go through like
eight times the toilet paper well guess
what so
that's why that's true they sent you one
[ __ ] yeah you got one coming oh [ __ ]
jack yeah and what you're gonna do is
you're going to take paula home you're
going to connect it and once she's
getting her muffler watch you're going
to like a little monkey and guess what
she's going to do a before and after
guess what guess what happens after you
do that
while she's getting the hot water in her
muffler you like a monkey what do you
think happens the stars she's moving in
the next day she's going to go home and
stab her mother in the neck
that's how good that is you're going to
take an around-the-world excursion you
understand me that's why i like this
product it's a tremendous little present
for the holidays for holiday whatever
you everybody i'm telling you
everybody 69s and you smell something if
you smell something
that person needs hellotushy.com right
now i'm excited to get it because it
looks easy to install real easy and i'm
a dunce
um putting stuff together like i i can't
do anything so if i can do it literally
anybody could do it so i'll just we'll
report in
my brother i'm happy
where you're at in your life i'm happy
you know you always got my help if you
need someone you gotta do the same goes
to you brother i'm happy where you're at
i'm happy you're not [ __ ] in the the
realm of uh beyond the realm of death
you look good you look healthy thanks
man you got family close to you again
and that's and hari's back hopefully
soon
lisa yet yes sir get this podcast up
we're going to austin texas cox sucking
about two hours let's do this let's do
it we got a private jet coming to pick
us up we're going we're going to tito
barrow we're going to miami to pick up
the sound machine
we're going to stop by houston and pick
up [ __ ] el chapo
and then we're going straight to [ __ ]
uh austin texas champo's coming chapel's
coming nice that's how we [ __ ] roll
listen i'll be in austin thursday friday
saturday there's a few tickets left
capital city and don't forget next
weekend i'm an nyc
friday saturday two shows friday two
saturday gotham comedy club again few
tickets left stay black we'll be back
next monday night rip ripping this
[ __ ] one more time for my
brother jason tebow one more time for my
little brother mr lee cyat this bad
[ __ ] who i love
where's the [ __ ] new chucks get the
brisket ready austin that's right
[ __ ] you come in and eat i'll
see you [ __ ] for lunch tomorrow
stay black suck it uncle joey jason
tebow my main man lisa
oh
so
so
you